(gentle instrumental music)
- [Voiceover] Sudan,
Najin,
Fatu.
These are the last three
northern white rhinos
left in the world.
They're here at Ol Pejeta
Conservancy in Kenya.
Efforts by the staff and veterinarians
are their last chance to keep these rhinos
from going extinct completely.
- My name is Doctor Stephen Ngulu.
I work at Ol Pejeta Conservancy
as the wildlife veterinarian.
Poachers have been the main cause
of the loss of this subspecies.
There's huge demand for rhino
horn and rhino products.
If there wasn't a demand
for it, for rhino horn,
there wouldn't be poaching.
It's like the war against terrorism.
It is a very dangerous kind of situation.
- [Voiceover] The northern white rhinos
were brought to the conservancy in 2009,
from a zoo in the Czech Republic.
Even though they live on the conservancy,
they're still at risk from poachers.
To keep the rhinos safe, they're
watched around the clock.
- [Voiceover] The keepers are keenly aware
that the rhinos have been brought here
to live out their last days.
So far, breeding efforts
have been unsuccessful
and though the chances
are slim, around 30%,
the last hope they have is to
try in-vitro fertilization.
(gentle instrumental music)